في الطريق الى الولايات المتحده عبر
بولندا في الشهر العاشر من الحرب يغادر
الرئيس الاوكراني
اول مره منذ نشوب الصراع تعددت اوصاف
الزياره تاريخيه ورمزيه وباللغه الاهميه
بنظره حلفائك بالنسبه لزلنسكي فهي لتعزيز
الصمود والقدرات الدفاعيه لاوكرانيا يلتقي
الرئيسان في المكتب البيضاوي
لثاني مره سبق ان استقبل بايدا سيلنسكي في
سبتمبر العام الماضي خرج حينها الضيف
الاوكراني بوعد من واشنطن لانها ستحميها
من روسيا وهذه المره قولا وفعلا سيعود
زينسكي بحزمه مساعدات يراد بها تغيير
خريطه المعارك بعد ان تبدلت حدود اوكرانيا
بعد ثلاث ايام من الصراع المسلح العابر
بتداعياته القارات اخيرا ستشمل مساعده
واشنطن الجديده منظومه الو
اعلام امريكيه قد تصلوا الشحنه الى هناك
في غضون وقت قريب بدا ان استخدمها في
المعركه قد يستغرق شهورا فقبلها ينبغي
تدريب القوات الاوكرانيه عليها لا خير في
الزياره علقت موسكو قال المتحدث باسم
الكريم لاند ميتري بيسكوف ان شحنات اسلحه
امريكيه جديده الى اوكرانيا لن تؤدي يا
سوى الى تفاقم النزاع مع روسيا استبعد في
سكوف اي تغيير في موقف
التفاوض مع الرئيس البوتان قبل ان تحط
طائره الضيف واشنطن
يرفعوا سقف تطوير القدرات العسكريه لبلاده
ويحدد ملامحها للعام القادم وعد بانه لا
حدود ماليه لما ستقدمه الحكومه الجيش
هذا العام تجاوز واحدا وتسعين في المئه
واعاده تجهيز افواج قوات الصواريخ
الاستراتيجيه منظومات افانكارد ما زالت
متواصله
المطول اتهم وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي
شويغو حلف الاطلسي بارسال ضباط الاركان
للمشاركه في العمليات العسكريه باوكرانيا
وفق الرئيس بوتين على مقترح وزير الدفاع
بزياده عديد القوات المسلحه الى مليون
ونصف مليون بمن فيهم 600 وخمسه وتسعون الف
جندي متعاقد خلال هذا الاجتماع سمعت اكثر
من مره جمله رفع مستوى استعداد الثالوث
النووي الروسي بما يضمن تحقيق التوازن
الاستراتيجي
في جبهات المشتعله صوت القص والمعارك يقول
ان حرب اوكرانيا ستدخل العام الجديد
باسلحه اكثر وفرص سلام اقل تعلن موسكو
سيطرتها على مرتفعات وخطوط اماميه في
دنياز ورواياتك تتحدث عن سحب روسيا لبعض
وحداتها القتاليه من الضفه الشرقيه للنهر
دنيترو اي فرقا ستحدثه زياره لهذه الحرب
المدمر والطويله والعابره للقارات
باجنداتها واسلحتها